mm go read my furtive her enjoy some
Smosh TTT with Ken what I think that was
right
you suck parent nobody's ready no matter
why oh damn it right no money leaves
this room no matter what okay if you're
leaving yeah that's really yeah i think
i think what guilty we're gonna let you
guard the wall yeah no you have a burger
and shut the [ __ ] up backwards like that
know what you're guilty oh they didn't
want to kill anyone until you know some
the whole time maybe Anthony I think
Anthony I had a I had a nice thing we
had a nice thing job jump up there I
can't even get up there don't feel the
climb that's so easily I trustee Ken
don't kill me okay I trust you I don't
trust them I don't trust them you
wounded I want to be able to kill you if
I if I happy it's so Anthony with the
fire me because you're here everyone I
hate them because I think they're guilty
stop following me and with the fog it's
not me he's right he's right next to you
Anthony shout out with you oh my god
what the hell do you think the only
explanation for it
for him trying to kill me is a gun - now
what's going on
and he's got a guy it's got a gut oh
he's got a gun he's got a gun guys I
just got a girl that doesn't work
yeah you said shield Thanks hey hey you
know it tricks me to think of the
music's gone all right guys don't reveal
each other for two minutes huh let's try
that
two-minute doing two-minute let's just
enjoy some Krabby Patties
yeah all right let's all sit down and
enjoy a krabby patty yeah if it it c.j
even though even if you're the traitor
but I mean you have to kill everyone all
right and sit down sit down in the
traitors lip at ease oh you're eating it
cute is this burger like nothing's wrong
now at nothing gets wrong because I have
my krabby patty oh god wait Ken did
something together yes I'm just saying
but I'm just a [ __ ] all right we can
talk about this I haven't no don't talk
no McIntosh all right everyone holster
your weapons ready wait yeah
a krabby patty what is that gun do
anyway I don't think they don't does no
it's like a bunch of stuff you guys
should just kill him anyway you're fine
only we had guns what you guys always
have something against me yeah like I
never killed me when I'm actually the
traitor but when I'm not you always kill
me here I don't like it can I trust you
can we all stand on each other's heads
yeah I can't trust here
oh let's do that let's do the stand on a
chair the head and the river moves ice
okay I'll say I didn't even get any guns
this is blenheim Ken and then you guys
can stand on each other I like you no
one kills each other tonight rusty can I
trust Ken right now I feel just like I
don't trust this guy over here that's
that's like well it's not me I swear to
god I'm just messing around I told you
it wasn't me oh [ __ ] it wasn't him
I am yeah it's the Indian right no I
told you it wasn't me [ __ ] you let me
stand on top of you the last one that I
kill it was true love when I was in love
with the traitor terror a movie in love
with the tree well better than you
Twilight disappear it to be like a that
that just you're way too good at that
let's get that strap this crowd you sure
and off you were just crazy
why does you die a lot of pinup
aggression you have what the game sorry
oh that dude dude that is nasty
that is nasty alright guys let's try not
kill each other this time shot who shot
here's to not that wasn't not me
who's shooting he's trying to draw us
away
I don't trust whoa whoa now mommy and
they stopped this can Bob you later talk
about this alright let's all talk it out
let's use words I don't like okay the
hallways I know one of you guys is
guilty I know it I think I was a traitor
last time it can't be me yeah you
haven't said to beat me every time geez
I want to stay here and reenact Forrest
Gump yeah yeah
look look me in the eyes and tell you
tell me I can trust you you could trust
me that's beautiful you can trust me
break you guys up because I am innocent
but I am NOT I am NOT where you guys are
yeah I saw him in the background
he's over there I will kill you yeah
that's really innocent of you I told you
I was innocent
alright that's on your face yeah I told
you okay are you guys just killed him no
Felix didn't even bat an eye he just
said let's go beyond the slightest him
yes feel
I'm going down to flower
oh sorry where is he where is he though
I don't know right now oh my god he
already went down the slide
what where is he she went down the slide
not in C yeah they're talking about oh
stop shooting towards me you crazy you
you're gonna get someone hurt next to
the kiddie pool shut up ghost oh yeah
I see you I see oh why you shooting at
me who's shooting at me okay it's
definitely nicer and all you guys are in
red health but all you guys are like
just about to die a lot in farallon's
and help save you guys okay give me
cover no you're way too good at this and
I like you I'm good in you wouldn't be
even be my barrel cover what the hell
this is you Eliot one health for like
what is wrong do you barrel you're going
in to pay no damn young Mario's gotta be
so suspicious and has any why you got
always gotta be so I'm just a nice guy
like I'm good at making everyone not
believe it's me that moment I have
weekend and it was a beautiful I'll say
it's kind of easy to turn everyone
against each other when everyone's just
shooting each other for no reason
let's all be civil people here said I'm
just gonna sit in this corridor and aim
down it with the right truth there's no
reason to be fighting why did you shoot
me because I don't know I thought maybe
I [ __ ] someone just moan was that
decided death or is that a plane
it was not a pleasure mode I guarantee
you he just killed for no reason and
he's not saying a word he's down there
don't watch out watch out
always cover come on I'll be your cover
take cover in I don't want you to die oh
damn it just being in take cover in I'll
help you now don't run away more come on
man it's obvious
15:53 oppa dildo is in trouble oh yeah
he's in trouble oh but they loved always
in trouble although community in trouble
we shoot through the fire let's get him
let's get him Ken we have to be stronger
next time I love you oh wait wait that
barrel lovin I will have none of it for
dad I love him come here can I love you
now oh okay let's not kill each other
for the first five seconds five seconds
five oh [ __ ] I dropped my gun
I don't okay no guns no guns Oh God okay
six to get home that's all this is wait
I guess there's like a thing under each
first name it says that says Puetz is
trigger-happy Ian's reputable ken is
reputable as well yeah why am i
trigger-happy
I don't know you're sure you're happy I
think that's guilty I'll just talk about
our feelings yes all right guys so uh
yeah yeah well like what about the game
the other day was uh pretty good it's so
good
yeah yeah my left looks mighty fine yeah
oh my god we're all look I got it go
what the hell oh yeah I like this right
what yeah I didn't buy those shoes
they're amazing Ian I have something for
you if you'd like it you got it you got
it Bob your head is he talked as it
looks very very good
come on you drop the c4 it was a gift
hope you bros enjoy the video never like
so I can start a Twitter team all right
do you see this move fish whatever bump